IN THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO,
ONE OF THE PRETTIEST PLACES IN
THE UNITED STATES, LAW AND ORDER
HAS BEEN EFFECTIVELY SUSPENDED
THANKS TO LEFT-WING PROSECUTORS.
PEOPLE CAMP ON THE SIDEWALKS, IN
PUBLIC, USE DRUGS IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT, ALL WITHOUT PENALTY.
THAT'S BAD ENOUGH.
FOR PART TWO OF OUR WEEK LONG --
CUSTOMERS CAN STEAL WITH
IMPUNITY.
HERE'S THE CONVERSATION.
[BLEEP] [BLEEP] >> THIS IS A DAY
IN THE LIFE OF --
>> I'VE BEEN HERE 42 YEARS.
HE RUNS A GROCERY STORE.
HOW OFTEN DO PEOPLE COME IN AND
CREATE PROBLEMS IN THE STORE
CUSTOMER >> EVERY DAY.
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> IT'S NOT AN EXAGGERATION.
CUSTOMERS WERE PICKING UP
POCKETS WITH MERCHANDISE AND
WALKING OUT OF THE STORE.
>> IT HAPPENS EVERY FEW MINUTES.
LITERALLY IN OUR STORE, PROBABLY
15-20 TIMES A DAY.
>> 20 TIMES A DAY?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> Tucker: THE
DECRIMINALIZATION OF CRIME HAS
BEEN A DISASTER.
>> ONE WAS THE LAST TIME YOU
CAME INTO WORK AND HAD A DAY
WHERE NOTHING WENT WRONG?
>> IT'S BEEN MANY YEARS.
>> Tucker: HE IS BEEN ATTACKED
BY THE HOMELESS TWICE IN HIS OWN
STORE.
ONE WOMAN BIT HIM WHEN HE ASKED
HER TO LEAVE.
>> SHE BIT INTO MY ARM.
I FREAKED OUT.
>> Tucker: THOSE WHO CALL ON
THE LAW ARE HELPLESS WHILE
CRIMINALS REIGNED SUPREME.
THIS FOOTAGE SHOWS A MAN RAKING
INTO THE STORE.
>> HE RANG UP $30,000 WORTH
OF --
>> HOW OFTEN DO YOU SEE PEOPLE
DOING DRUGS?
>> OH, MY --
>> Tucker: SOMEONE HAD
ATTEMPTED TO STEAL SOME OF THE
COUNTERFEIT MONEY THAT HE TAPES
TO THE WALL BEHIND THE CASH
REGISTER.
>> THIS IS LOW-INCOME HOUSING
AND SOME OF THEM HAVE ISSUES.
SOMETIMES THEY PASS OUT.
WATER PENETRATES THE CEILING.
IT HAPPENS EVERY MONTH PRETTY
MUCH.
>> Tucker: HOW MUCH YOU PAY IN
TAXES EVERY YEAR?
>> THOUSANDS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND DOLLARS.
>> Tucker: WHY ARE YOU STILL
IN SAN FRANCISCO?
>> WELL, BECAUSE YOU MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN BUSINESSES.
YOU CAN'T JUST PICK UP AND LEAV
LEAVE.
>> I LIVE A BLOCK AWAY.
[BLEEP] YOU!
>> HE WAS ON THE PHONE WITH THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
>> YOU HAVE ANGRY PEOPLE ACROSS
THE STREET WHO CAN'T AFFORD IT
BECAUSE THEY ARE LEAVING
BECAUSE THEY ARE LIVVING
BECAUSE THEY ARE LIVINNG
BECAUSE THEY ARE LIVING IN
POVERTY.
I'M SCARED FOR MY SAFETY.